1000 entreprises abonnés mais du jour au
lendemain une activité réduite à zéro
pour l'entreprise plaisir fruité le
confinement a été synonyme d'une mise au
chômage partiel de sa trentaine de
salariés mais une fois passé les
premiers jours de résignation ses deux
fondateurs ont trouvé une autre solution
le 16 mars
bah tout a changé puisque au début on
pensait devoir fermer la société puisque
nos clients sont uniquement des bureaux
donc tous en télétravail tout le monde a
arrêté donc on a on a décidé du coût
pour le client qui restait de fermer la
société on s'est converti à la livraison
aux particuliers
donc bon c'était un domaine qu'on ne
sait pas du tout jusqu'à présent vous
vraiment que du 8 au 10 et là on est
passés donc en be to see et on a fait
également un petit peu de ventes en
direct ici dans l'entrepôt ce qui a
permis également de dépanner pas mal et
les personnes du coin ne savait pas trop
où aller ça évitait aussi toutes les
grandes que puisque au début tout le
monde se jeter dans les grandes surfaces
depuis trappe la quinzaine de livreurs
oeuvre donc pour les particuliers à
travers l'ile-de-france en 48 heures le
site internet a été repensé pour des
commandes en ligne
6000 ont été passés lors des quatre
dernières semaines et les locaux sont
ouverts ponctuellement au public
résidant à proximité
une solution qui a aussi permis d'éviter
de perdre 8 à 9 tonnes de marchandises
dans un premier temps mais aussi par la
suite de proposer des légumes on se dit
que pour avoir une offre complète on
veut faire également du légume pour
qu'on en faisait un petit peu mais là on
est très vite arrivée sur des volumes
assez important donc on a
on avait des fournisseurs sur un juste
me connaissait déjà bien sûr la partie
légumes on a traité
on l'a traité avec eux et on a commencé
à faire énormément de deux sachets de
légumes également c'est un des produits
qui se vendent le plus à la fin du
confinement l'entreprise pourrait
maintenir son activité en direction des
particuliers malgré le retour progressif
des abonnements d'entreprise